on saturday the st louis federal reserve
tweeted a preposterous tweet they said
from the fred blog a thanksgiving dinner
serving of poultry cost 1.42 cents a
soybean-based dinner serving with the
same amount of calories costs 66 cents
and provides almost twice as much
protein i'm not making this up this is
literally what the st louis fed tweeted
on saturday and so of course i stepped
in and i said listen i don't think
anyone is looking for nutrition advice
from a central bank it would be easier
for you all to curtail the persistently
high inflation that you created rather
than take on a national nutrition
campaign so we literally have central
banks saying listen don't worry about
increasing prices instead what you
should do you should buy a different
food that you might not have wanted
previously and if you buy that different
food not only will you get better
nutritious value but it's also cheaper
to go ahead and use that for your
thanksgiving meal this is insane instead
of focusing on what the nutrition is or
focusing on what else you could buy the
central bank has two specific mandates
their job is to get full employment and
stable prices they do not have full
employment we have over 4.5 unemployment
in the united states right now we have
11 million open jobs so obviously
there's a disconnect in the economy but
also we do not have stable pricing we
have had persistently high five plus
percent cpi for the last number of
months we now are sitting at 6.2 percent
cpi what is the highest cpi in record in
over a decade and we continue to only
see inflation going higher and higher
that's why central banks are having to
post things like this do not go ahead
and eat what you want to do on
thanksgiving a thanksgiving dinner
serving up poultry costs a dollar 42 but
a soybean based dinner serving with the
same amount of calories costs 66 cents
and provides almost twice as much
protein this is insane i don't want a
soybean based dinner instead what i want
is i want poultry that is what people
want to eat on thanksgiving they should
not have to change what they eat because
of central bank decision we've
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
in this country and people are suffering
the top 55 of americans are getting
richer and richer because they hold
investable assets the bottom 45 of
americans are getting absolutely crushed
and so in order to try to curtail the
impact rather than change the monetary
or fiscal policy rather than address the
actual issue to look at this from a
first principle standpoint we have
central banks that are tweeting out what
you should eat how much it costs what
the calories are and how much protein
you will receive as i said nobody wants
their nutrition advice from a central
bank they want disciplined predictable
monetary policy from the central bank
and they'll leave the nutrition to
healthcare professionals doctors
nutritionists and their own research we
do not want to live in a society where
your diet restrictions or your diet
decisions are driven by your monetary
policy decisions of the appointed
officials at the central bank instead
what we need is we need to have clear
concise predictable and transparent
stable monetary policy something that we
can count on something that does not
debase the currency you simply do that
you fix the monetary policy then people
won't have to change their diets they
won't have to go look for more protein
lower cost and eat soybeans for
thanksgiving